all right welcome back to today's
channel where we don't upload that often
the reason the craft takes time exactly
craft I had crafted my edits I don't
just slap it together and craft it
together it takes time okay but yeah
sorry for the long wait for the wedding
video I decided to take on the edit
myself rather than hiring people to edit
it we did hire people to help shoot it I
even had my friend 8k and shoot it so
multiple cameras happy wedding and you
know we had really good coverage and
looking at the footage I was like I
think I could do this footage justice
you know because it comes from a very
personal place you know I'm going to
edit and I put it like my heart and soul
into everything I don't just smile
together and say your work because if
you feel something when you watch the
videos you know heart and soul went into
it if you don't feel anything then you
know I kind of slept together
so we're recording this video this is
like what this is one day before we're
gonna upload the wedding video so by
this time you should have seen the
wedding video if not go check out the
wedding video first if not stay here and
watch this video and then I don't know
but anyways I've decided to record gifs
reaction to the wedding video what the
last time I regretted not recording your
reaction was when I first showed you the
video to our proposal and I showed her
she started crying and had all these
like very just insightful loving
nurturing caring wife type things to say
and I was like I should be recording all
of this ya know I just I just thought
like we missed that opportunity then and
I really want to capture it now not only
do I kind of wish I would have seen my
reaction as well because it was a really
beautiful video to witness because I had
I wasn't there throughout that whole
process and I to see it through your
perspective and to see you ask Isaac for
permission that was like the sweetest
thing ever and that'll be really cool to
see my own reaction but yeah it since
you did decide to take on this edit
like okay wait we gotta film my erection
because this entire time he hasn't shown
me any piece of this edit so I haven't
seen any of it it's been a top secret it
had kind of been working like downstairs
this whole time I barely get to see him
because if I'm not at the office and if
I'm home and he's like locked away in
another part of the house because he's
working on this secretly it's been a
lonely process for over the last two
weeks but uh I'm excited are finally
done you're done too and I'm sure you
guys are really happy it's finally done
you guys seem it by the time you see
this so I'm so excited to see it oh just
do it
Oh am I gonna need tissues yes I am
thank you are you ready yes I'm sorry
I'm like trying so hard I didn't put
eyeliner on purpose and then knew I was
gonna pull my eyes I should have put
waterproof mascara honestly I cry life
to me okay I just watch it I have you
got ready three two one as I start to go
up
[Music]
young makers a woman that she is right
now and because of that I love you so
much thank your levity won't be the end
every time I've never take it off Isaac
look still happy today I could
definitely see
the get married and to know that this is
a permanent thing in his life
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is what I call my carrot level ou
bought this one Tiffany I feel like our
relationships literally walked out of a
movie and it exists in real life I don't
believe in about that first sight but
when I first thought you I thought man I
have to talk to her and I have to deal
with her and it wasn't it either it
wasn't instantly that we were together
over time though I think through my
persistence I think I finally got to you
and we started dating pretty soon we
moved in together and we started a life
together through that I feel like we've
literally blossomed into a perfect
couple and I don't want to brag but I
honestly think that we have a perfect
relationship and I honestly believe that
we will have a perfect marriage and I
promise to you that I will be recruited
over there through the dark times and
the low times I promised you that I will
make thee things brighter and higher for
you and I promise to all of our children
just as equally no matter through a lot
of your blood and I promised me that
he'll be the perfect partner your best
friend this step
the cats they play them some carbon
thanks I feel like are the hardest
things to promise simply just being side
by side and being happy I think those
are Hardison's our promise all those
small moments the most important moments
the ones that are overlooked those will
also be perfect now we'll never take
that for granted and I won't take you
for granted and I love you I feel like
I'm dreaming right now
growing up my entire life I always
constantly would wish they could like
turn back time and change my path
whatever you went through in life and
meeting you really showed me that I
needed to go through everything I went
through because it led me to you it's
not where to speak but you know how I
feel inside and you know everything
we've been through in my mind just went
blank helped me grow into the person I
am today
and I will forever be grateful for that
and I just paused to be the best wife I
can be your best friend forever and I'll
always be your number one fan no matter
what and I'm just really looking forward
to what the future holds for us I love
you
they've reached out that too by the way
that wasn't written that's amazing at
times we'll work late because of decade
news would you like to exchange links
[Music]
it's gonna be a hell yeah holiday can I
say hell yeah no we're not a church I
now pronounce you KC
and Tiffany check you may now kiss the
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
very larger than life
I love that long walk it's my fave
that with us like our intimate moment
just the two of us beautiful you know my
dad needs a me like stole the show up
for like they got sitting by the bed
my mom thank you so much for being here
it means the world to me
it's all here like choking us so I'm
like oh I can't finish this number one
thing you taught me was ABC always be
closing I remember that I was it then
you taught me always be closing I was
like oh that's That's Life that's life
Gary rise also very happy for you too
and congratulations and hope you guys
have a happy ending for the rest of your
life if anybody else wants to call up
here and say something I think
that's really great I'm glad now Casey
is officially my dad and I'm glad
everybody got it came through this
moment where my now dad
my very happy for both of these parents
of mine yeah I'm very happy for you too
and I'll always love you too forever and
ever until now until adjustments of
human beings
a little small stake in a speech in my
truck
[Music]
everyone has lat
Oh Michael that thing's sort of excited
feeling you get when you sleep over your
best friend's house you're just having
the greatest time realizing you never
want it to end I feel like that today
but times a million because I know that
this is never gonna end I get to have a
special sleepover with my best friend
for the rest of my life and I'm so happy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
the cameraman never Joe Oh beautiful
I went away mm white tonight let's watch
it again you made it
like I said really yeah and every when I
saw the old footage I was like yeah yeah
I know I used to let me get the old hard
drive you're like what are you doing the
whole hard drive I was like I don't know
like are you not working on the video I
want to see it or it's all part of the
process you know what though I thought
it was really cool how you edited your
entire mouth to kind of look like
Pixar's up but yeah I guess is it yeah
like when they actually paint their
whole love story and that's what you did
with your mouth that's the part that
really got me where I was like you see a
progression don't ya so now that was
really beautiful I loved it
honestly I want that entire wedding bow
edit and I just want to say that part
forever that was obviously my favorite
part in the whole video I almost call it
a movie just know as I was editing you
know the old footage into this stuff and
I realized how far we've come and I'm
like
don't even really know why we started
flogging I thought it was just something
fun to do it together
having edited the old footage now I'm
kind of seeing some form of a full
circle thing happening with life you
know like oh we're creating memories
we're creating these some very intimate
moments and home movies and so I get
really kind of gave me this perspective
of like we're making it for future
selves to see like I think a CI future
did it I mean that's the reason why I
wanted to start this channel at the
beginning was because I wanted us to
really capture our memories and cement
it in in a video format where we can
really look back on in the future so you
know we should start doing what we
should just start doing all of our
videos or we just address our future
selves like Oh future like hi future
tiffin case and future Isaac and future
children watching this cuz then our
future kids how it'd be awesome yeah I
get your kids are gonna be looking at
this video you'll be like oh so that's
how mom reacted when dad created me so
good so it's video addressing our future
okay future Casey yeah future Casey do I
look as good as you do now or no I don't
know it depends on what your future case
you're talking about ten years from now
20 years from now 50 years from now or a
month from now case a month Casey you'd
be looking a lot better than I do right
now what what are some memories from the
wedding that we didn't get to capture
because since we didn't vlog that day I
try an action there's like the read
clips of me and vlogging in the morning
with Isaac maybe two clips at the
wedding venue and then I realize how
nervous I was and I was like
not a vlogging day is too much to handle
right now I know we actually took two
cameras to Paris for us to vlog on the
wedding date but then by the time it
actually happened and I remember you
asking me like are you gonna take the
camera and I'm like I don't want to deal
with the camera right on Marian we were
so ambitious going there by timing shot
there and everything caught up socialite
yeah yeah I know you know it's 22 I took
like a gardener for you to do the whole
garter thing when the guy takes it off
with their teeth yeah I took it to Paris
and I forgot to put it on I forgot about
the whole thing and I know a lot of
people are asking to if I even okay toss
and I did but by the time I did it all
the video guys were gone and then we
weren't blogging and we were kind of
tipsy by then because we're drinking a
lot of champagne yeah so my cousin ended
up catching and keeping it Samantha
lives out there so yeah the whole day
which is either drunk on nervous and
this drunk on happiness or drunk on
champagne you feel any emotion or drunk
on emotion yeah you pick your poison
that was the whole day so there wasn't a
moment where we were clear-headed and
like oh yeah this nice we should do that
we should do this yeah gonna do that
just another memory that popped in my
head
David didn't know that he was gonna be a
fish joining our wedding which he
telling this story like it's my fault
but no what really happened here is
throughout the whole time that we were
planning for the wedding I kept asking
him either during janeers or during
breaks or whenever we would see him I
asked him at least I remember at least
three times I brought it up cuz David
even said once like I am done
officiating weddings like no more I was
like wait what you're doing ours right
he's like yeah no I'm like cool and then
another time it's like he David's over
you down into her wedding he's like yeah
for sure
yeah I'm down like cool and in the
second time with that whole one I just
mentioned and then the last one I
remember asking him I think we were
eating or something now's a wait David
so you are cool with doing our wedding
right he's like yeah for sure for sure
he never he says like he told me that we
would sit down and talk about it he
never mentioned it to me though I think
he said it in his own head because I
never got married
I didn't know we had to sit down and
actually discuss how this everybody was
gonna go so he never mentioned that to
me so I just am I asked him three times
already and then I can remember it's I'm
like okay he's got it he's good but I
did I did myself because I was gonna
bring it up for the last time in that
welcoming dinner but then you know being
caught up in the moment and everything I
come here you're not thinking straight
once you're in that arena of the wedding
you know it's like your mind kind of
goes out the door in your life I need
the wedding planner I need my friend I
need my mom yeah reminds me of all the
things I need to do that's what happened
it was like I don't want you to do and
then everyone comes to you like what are
you do this another oh yeah my stomach
drop cuz he came to me first
because he had the realization with Joe
and he was like JC media talk so am I
supposed to speak he came over he was so
friend I was about to get ready to walk
out he comes he's activity so I'm
supposed to be doing this wedding and I
was like David how do I look he's like
oh yeah you look beautiful but wait I'm
supposed to be doing this and I was like
yeah David we I asked you a lot of times
like how do you not know I felt so bad
that moment too and I was freaking out -
exactly hold on we're gonna get married
and you didn't know you're supposed to
officiate though she's freaking out but
I honestly like that the rest of the
conversation was kind of a blur because
I was just so like nervous and just
everything but yeah he ended up watching
I did an amazing job David you were
incredible you can't even tell that it
was just when he was honestly when he
came to me asking like if he was gonna
be the officiant I was trying to craft
my vows in my own head like we know how
we weren't writing it right I need an
ally
have an idea of what I was going to
start with and end with maybe and my
office fillings in the middle on the
spot and so I'm just trying to think and
I'm thinking my thoughts I'm like yeah
out of nowhere hey I'm gonna do this
thing right and I'm like okay screw the
balance for now yeah let's work on this
right now they go oh my god and then
after you came out from the talking to
you it was just me and David pacing back
and forth in the field everyone that
spoke at the wedding no one wrote
anything everything came from the heart
let's do David my brother my friend
Kevin and Isaac like nothing was perfect
no one knew they were gonna speak and
they're just kind of like oh yeah I'll
say something and everything came out so
poetically and so perfect and if you
were to write and I'm pretty sure it'd
be a lot more dull yeah for sure cuz URI
the girl who did my hair and makeup she
was her and her husband pet after the
little ceremony they came up to me and
they were like Tiffany that was the most
beautiful ceremony I think I've ever
witnessed and they were both like that
actually made me cry and they have seen
so many weddings because she does hair
and makeup so she's gone two rounds away
and she was just like this wedding this
one was genuine you could feel it like I
felt it in my heart but yeah when I was
getting ready for this
so I was sending geo and my cousin Jenny
I was sending them videos like me
getting ready and I was texting my
sister in Mexico and like I was just
trying to communicate with anyone that
wasn't at the wedding so I can make them
feel involved too and like they're there
my sister was like we're ready by the
computer watch really cold and then it
was really awesome to hell like we
incorporated both of our culture's yeah
that's a tea ceremony during the whole
thing awesome Oh we'll be incorporated
two elements of the weddings from our
cultural aspects where instead of
wedding is its money right and because
during the tea ceremony you know you're
supposed to pay respects to your elders
and the elders pass on money or jewelry
and their words of wisdom for the
wedding and then money dance is kind of
like the same thing where it's like you
know you have family members coming up
to you giving you money but it's you
know it's kind of like an offering for
your future yeah sounds like oh it
weren't in the same from our different
cultures so I thought that's pretty cool
the whole tea ceremony thing I think we
agreed to do it maybe the last minute it
was really last minute I think like a
week before we left to go to Paris and
so Christina went with me to go by the
Chinese dress and it was so cool because
the very first story that we walked into
and the very first dress that I tried on
is the one I ended up leaving with
because immediately one side zip tit up
it would fit like a glove it was like
this dress is meant to be mine and I got
kind of a little bit emotional too and I
was wearing it cuz and then I saw
Christina - she's trying to she got a
little choked up but she was just like
this dress is made for you it's amazing
and then the lady - from the store she
didn't give me a discount because up she
was like this dresses for years like you
look amazing in it and I was like I feel
amazing
yeah it's so cool and then the whole
money dancing - it was funny because the
song that we wanted to play it didn't
play it's like cuz we wanted the song by
landon iman maybe on that
I think there's fun anymore so it's a
band of lemon singing about orange
yeah but anyways we have a specific song
which is like Casey's favorite song
Mexican on that song that's a dope song
and play though the DJ instead of just
searching some random song those coming
yeah I think it just multiple songs
called that yeah I think got the wrong
one by the time we started dancing of
the song that we wanted oh well it's our
fault because we didn't even specify
yeah we were just we shot everything was
alert it really wasn't like if you guys
are getting married just know that
you're whining cause I'm so bad I really
wish I could redo it because I feel like
not that it was bad or anything no it's
just that it went by too fast to a point
where it's like oh we even said this to
ourselves like walk after the ceremony
the Western ceremony walked up to the
building the petiole yeah it's like just
us to enjoy this this is like
once-in-a-lifetime so a wedding day and
enjoy it because I know for sure we're
gonna regret not enjoying it enough yeah
and sure enough we didn't enjoy it
enough besides that long walk there was
no other moment that whole day that we
really could just soak it in and just
relish in her way it was literally just
that walk there are many people coming
at you with a million things and you're
not singing
to talk and you deal with things as I
was that's really hard to enjoy your own
way haha
and then so I was kind of about to
because I heard that the canapes that
appetizer igniters uh what are they
called poor girl yeah I don't know on
the menu this is canapes but i mean to
my knowledge from watching movies
everyone's always calm orders yeah I
don't know
nasty finger foods that come out on
platters yeah during the cocktail hour
every while we were taking photos
everyone was enjoying the hors d'oeuvres
and everyone was saying like they were
amazing so while we were taking photos
and the wedding planner she comes over
with the platter of some of these orders
but it was like cheese with way and some
cucumber yeah I was like cucumber so it
was it was so good but the whole tray
was just that so I was kind of we didn't
have the far right thanks I kind of wish
I would it's cuz everyone was just
raving about them so that was pretty
good but if the quality of that of the
ones we did try was an indication of how
good it was then it was phenomenal
apparently Isaac you like six or seven
of this one like chicken one yeah I feel
like Isaac was the one that fully
enjoyed the wedding day everything was
about him - yeah but then he wasn't
occupied with everything else so he was
just like he was the most hungry nah
yeah it was the most free because
everyone else you know I think being a
grown-up - it's like you know you have
to kind of mingle you know and talk to
the family talk to their friends and has
a grown oh that's kind of like the the
nature of conducting yourself this but
for kids though you know you don't have
to conduct yourself a certain way you
know no one's gonna hold you to it so he
was able to be in his own world and in
detail and really relish it you know he
was even cuz this bathroom was
downstairs like yes but he was by the
bathroom like I don't know it was a good
door guys cuz I was like Isaac you find
yourself a part-time job - Kuwaiti you
know I realized - I didn't go to the
restroom the whole time over there
that's not healthy I had to just I
didn't drink enough or I don't know but
I never saw it yeah but I kind of wish I
wouldn't see him cause he apparently
like the doorman so we did include this
in the main video but what we did when
we were up there doing our little
speeches we actually spoke to every
single table yes I actually really liked
how small our wedding was because we
were able to address every single person
and that's exactly what we did we
literally spoke to every single person
during the banquet before we eat dinner
and then in the middle of that Gina was
actually facetiming with Martin Gio at
that moment so then I started speaking
to her and then Gina is like she's wait
your sugar here sells like oh hey and
then you just hear Bart saying hey guess
what I'm doing right now in the middle
of me penance he like was really
beautiful each the both of them he's
like guess what I'm doing and then they
pan down and this goes on the toilet
he's like I'm pooping and I was like
kerley what what and your aunt your aunt
with the closest to the phone and she's
like he's pooping like that's funny but
you're gonna ruin the whole thing I was
like oh sorry I can't even notice my
heart it was it was barks way Bartha
weird dude that's way of saying this is
how important your wedding is even when
I need to take a boom I'm gonna be there
for your wedding I can't be there a
person and I need to take a poop I'm
gonna be there you know that's a
hospital you know what's funny important
you are definitely meant to be because
when I was sending her videos before the
ceremony she sent me a video back and
she's like I'm so happy for you and Myka
but I'm sorry right now I'm on the
toilet I'm pooping but I love you in
love like what's up with them improve
that's how they communicate with us
around the toilet thinking low fighting
I'm glad that barbed you were able to
tune in you know and segment several
weddings that I was pretty cool and I
honestly wish I could just go back in
time and relive that whole day over and
over and over again but it's my real
sport I wanna say that what I can thanks
to this beautiful video you more excited
about the wedding or you're more excited
about getting dressed up
[Music]